hello everyone today we're gonna do a
little bit of real physics not some you
know not what we hear about there in the
everyday news blogs or articles by what
the specialized manga specialized
journals and the popularization
magazines today we do real physics so
what is real physics what do we do in
physics let's start out with the
etymology says that physics comes from
the Greek that's that those fancy
letters there stands for physics or
physique a something along those line
and it means nature one person put
somewhere that I read thought I'd
include they're common in here the laws
of nature can be used to predict the
behavior of the world and all kinds of
machinery okay so people are thinking a
little bit about technology I guess when
they talk about physics
that's the etymology that's where where
it comes from so physics means nature
and I suppose it's the study of nature
knowledge of nature and the purpose I
guess is to develop technology that
that's what you know the etymology and
the word nature seems to suggest when
you look up the word in the in the on
the internet you'll find the following
here's one prominent site says what is
physics I like this because they start
out with a disclaimer to be artists it's
really difficult to define exactly what
physics is that's that's the first
statement I read I said oh my god this
is gonna be a good one for one physics
keeps changing as we progress and make
new discoveries and this
true I mean if you compare anything be
for the ninth 19th century or before
anything before the 20th century it was
what we call today or what
the mathematicians called today
classical mechanics and we don't do
classical anymore except maybe in high
school when you get to the 20th century
you start doing some of the stuff they
do in college at the university level
and at that point you go into something
else and that's to into fantasy into
irrationality and those irrationalities
the dual irrationalities are known as
quantum mechanics and general relativity
they only have irrational physical
interpretations only and says new
theories don't just bring new answers
they also create new questions that
might not have even made sense when we
beaut when viewed from within the
previous theory of physics
this makes physics exciting and
interesting great but it also forces
attempts at defining physics into
generalizations about what physics has
been rather than what it might be at
some point in the future okay that's one
version that was a prominent sight by
the way you can look up the words and
you'll find out who I'm talking about
yeah well another sight says what is
physics physics a natural science again
that word natural in there right based
on experiments measurements and
mathematical analysis experiments
measurements mathematical analysis no
inclusion of explanations no physical
interpretations no trying to figure out
what gravity or or magnetism or light or
the atom is or look like they're talking
about science a natural science and the
way you explain science science is
explanation so especially what they're
saying is is is a natural explanation
based on an experiment
and what I'm referring to is the three
criteria that they use experiments
measurements and mathematical analysis
well I'm saying that none of that has
anything to do with science let alone
with physics
you need some starting point yeah but
none of you dropped a pen before you
know there's the gravity of the earth
they explain but all all of all that
starting point none of the starting
points includes experiments measurements
and mathematical analysis
neither of three which belong either to
science or to physics they have nothing
to do with science they have nothing to
do with physics that's the point so you
know I was struck by this because they
there's the finding what is physics and
and they're putting three things that at
least I will object to violently I do it
now I know experiment we don't do
experiments in science we don't do
experiments in physics what we do is
explain them not do them I don't know
about who does them someone can tell me
about it you know the technician does
experiments the engineer interprets them
and figures out how to fix the problems
because that's what it is in other words
were referring to the guy who does the
hands-on who gets his hands dirty in the
lab that's not a scientist he can run
the experiment all day not understand
anything he just comes back with the
dataset here boss this what I found
he doesn't have to hurt his his job he
doesn't get paid to interpret it you can
have an observation you know the apple
fell from the tree now experiment right
it's not an experience well it's not an
experiment in the sense there's a
difference between an observation and an
experiment experiment you deliberately
do something observation just happens
same thing we don't observe we don't
gawk in science you know we don't doctor
you've got a nice plane
right yeah you only know they exist
because you've seen them no no I haven't
seen them in fact one guy that just
recently died one guy that just recently
died mr. stephen hawking he never saw a
black hole in his life he was the king
of black holes he never saw the black
hole in his life he probably never
looked through a scope at the universe
maybe maybe a couple times in his life
certainly he was not an astronomer like
you know he didn't he didn't do the lab
work you know what and and and and what
I'm saying is he could be blind for all
it's got nothing to do with math at all
it's not about holes maybe about black
holes because they did exactly right but
what no I was referring to something
else I'm saying first even Hawking never
saw he never did any experiment he never
did any observation in his life
mathematical analysis no no holy holy
let's get the experiment though don't go
into you can't bring that up because
they hit that one too
yeah yeah let's go one step at a time
saying experiments has nothing to do
with physics or science so let's stick
with first with the word experiments if
experiments or observations right I'm
saying here you have a guy like Stephen
Hawking he never observed or did an
experiment in his entire life so
experiment and an observation is not
part of the scientific method
mathematical analysis we'll get to it in
a minute but right now we're dealing
with the word experiment I'm saying that
has nothing to do with science we don't
observe and we don't do experiments we
explain them that's the only correct and
we're gonna get to the others I'm gonna
get to the others okay let's go with the
other criteria experiments I already
ruled out right you did why not
have you brought in an example I guess
you need to give me an example yeah but
it would fall under experiments
measurements or mathematical
well first I reject experiments I'll get
that same I'll use that same example
against mathematical analysis and
measurements but at least you know if if
Stephen Hawking never observed or did an
experiment on black holes and and he
connects he goes in there and tries to
analyze him and explain them describe
them whatever
obviously you know you don't need the
experi doesn't need to do an experiment
he doesn't personally need to observe
anything someone can tell him about it
yes if he doesn't do it experiment then
he has to do one of the other two yeah
correct it has to hit one of these okay
one of these all I'm saying is here
personally I'm saying him person he
never did an experiment in his life
probably and he certainly did not
observe black holes we'll get through
that in a second what I'm saying he
never did an experiment and obviously he
he could go in there and analyze
describe do mathematics do measurements
or whatever but he didn't do
measurements either but but he can do
all kinds of mathematical analysis on
him right he can do that but he
personally did not need to observe or do
an experiment that's what I'm saying no
it is relevant because I want to scratch
out the word experiment okay I'm saying
we reject experiments be able to
experiment okay first one experiments
ruled out no experiments ruled out
because Stephen Hawking never had to do
okay that's a separate issue that's a
separate task we're not gonna see eye to
eye on these pheromone oh yeah you
haven't ruled you haven't showed me
where I fail on the word experiment or
observation yeah how this works well
they give one that hits all three no no
no Rose because they're worse they won't
they would have just gone physics
international science based on
experiments period then you wouldn't be
right no no holy let's get that right no
way no way no way
now Stephen Hawking never did an
experiment in his life he need to never
did an observation yeah that doesn't
mean that he can't do mathematical
analysis
so if mathematical analysis is a
criteria for physics let us assume that
then it's okay you can say look physics
is a natural science based on
mathematical analysis all the other we
scratch out and then no problem because
someone can come to him and say look I
saw I didn't not be an experiment or I
made an observation and this is what I
observed this is what I had is that the
data collected
please analyze it he he's he's in a
wheelchair obviously he couldn't go to a
lab or do things with his arms so he
sits at his desk and he does
mathematical analysis on what someone
fed him he could be blind for all we
know he never had to observe anything he
never had to do an experiment what I'm
saying is he doesn't need an experiment
he if if if mathematical analysis is
physics is if it's a synonym was
synonymous with physics if physics is
about based on mathematical analysis
only only right then this means that
Stephen Hawking does not need to do
experiments or measurements he does not
need to have any mathematical analysis
or measurements that he does need an
experiment if he does what if he doesn't
have a measurement or mathematical
analysis then he does need an experiment
what I'm saying is someone can tell him
look I saw an asteroid hit hit the the
moon and please explain it or or
describe it or mathematically or
whatever he can come up with an equation
he never saw it he doesn't know if it's
for real he doesn't have the other guy
he never observed anything according to
this definition that's wrong someone
can't come and tell him fine why not
because it's not an experiment
measurement right and that's what I'm
saying that if if if one can't come and
tell if natural science based on only
mathematical analysis we do not need to
do experiments measurements or
observations
why not because someone because he could
do an experiment there's nothing to do
with math he drops the pen yeah there's
no math and if he doesn't drop the
measurement involved because the pencil
has a phenomenon is explained yeah
someone tells them about it imagine son
can't be told that's not in this well I
know but what I'm saying is there's he
can come up with he doesn't even have
it's not even he can invent something
that's not physics according to this
definition yes it is it doesn't say
because it says that it says that if
natural science if if I only take the
word mathematical analysis if if let's
assume that mathematical analysis is the
only criterion right well then then he
would be within science within physics
because he does mathematical analysis he
says you look physics is mathematical
analysis and I'm doing mathematical
analysis therefore I'm doing physics but
let's turn that around let's eliminate
mathematical analysis and measurement
let's say physics is experiments ok so I
do experiments because I go to the lab
or whatever but then that excludes
Stephen Hawking because he never did an
experiment in his life so he's not a
scientist under that criteria right so
we just limited to experiments he's not
a science you're no physicist and if he
and if he if science or physics is just
mathematical analysis that would exclude
the guy in the lab so it's like we're
saying look before to do physics we need
the guy in the lab at least whether it's
him himself or someone else doesn't
really matter in this case it means that
because you know I could also say well
this does this mean that a physicist has
to do all three
no it's or and not or experience
measurements and therefore therefore you
know if he didn't do you know
experiments in his entire life that we
exclude him as a physicist because oh
yeah
well this is just one of the I guess the
second most important one on the end
what does that mean well let's put or
okay let's put or let's see if it works
any better let's fix this a little
better okay let's see we have
experiments measurements and
mathematical analysis okay so let's say
it's based on experiments okay so the
lab boy you know the technician or
whatever yeah he does experiments he
doesn't do anything else right all day
long all his life all he did was the
experiments he's dropping panties
dropping pennies and so he's a scientist
he's a scientist because all he does his
experiments and so he's part of science
because there's an or there right the
other guy you know the what's the word
the guy who minted the surveyor he
measures the land he doesn't do any
experiments really just measures writers
the pen he measures everything he's the
scientist because it's one of the
criteria for for a physicist and the
other guy who sits in his office all day
long and just drink coffee and shoots
the ball he just those mathematical
analysis and therefore he's also fit so
we got three kinds of physicists and we
get them together and they make one
physicist and each one separately is a
physicist because we use the word or so
so we got so we got a problem that means
that yeah and my point is that so now we
killed them guy in the surveyor and we
killed the mathematical analyst and we
say ok here's Joey and what do you do
for a living well I work at
such-and-such place and I do experiments
all day long I collect data for for
someone oh you're a scientist he never
understood anything what he does he
doesn't he can't put him in any
mathematical format he can't make any
sense of it he can't explain it he can't
describe it mathematically or quality
you know he's a dumb person
just throws pen everyday I was told to
throw this a million times four days
right yet so what so what I was saying
you know is that a scientist if we just
do war well again if physics only
involves experiments without any
understanding without any measurements
without any equations or any
descriptions or that is that physics
just doing experiments and not
understanding anything just dropping the
pen every day or putting two magnets
together you know we have the pattern we
do this 20 times a day 100 times a day
and if you put them together into one
person the guy who goes out there does
the experiments comes to does his
measurement turns to his off collects
the data comes to his office and does
the calculation well now we got all
three of them right what happens if he
doesn't do one of those is he also
excluded from physics no no but assuming
he does all of them we have the word and
in there now instead of the word or
right then he's got to do all three and
if we exclude two of them a visit a 1/3
physicist so either way I think we have
a problem but assuming someone did have
all three if all you're doing is
dropping a pen many of how how wide the
pen is how tall the pen is how fast it
fell if you know all the parameters now
you calculate the speed of gravity I
mean you just have a lot of information
I'll do it even so in for me I'll do it
simpler for you here we have a chair you
don't have the crucial information that
tells you what gravity is like the whole
question is what is gravity and for
example so far that's the question
hopefully it what a physic we come to
the physicist I assume we wouldn't come
to the chemist for this and what is
gravity
canvases a better idea but I think any
normal person will go to a physicist and
if the physicist just spews numbers at
someone they're not left with an
understanding of what's going on well if
we continue we'll get to the exact point
that you just mentioned and here's
another site no well those were two
sites what I'm saying here is the first
site then says you know what do
physicists do what do they do for a
living what do they do every day and
here we have an answer fortunately you
know here it is and drumroll freeze okay
so we have what physicists are trying to
do what they're trying to do not what
they do but what they're trying to do
they they precisely define the most
fundamental measurable quantities in the
universe they measure they define
velocity electric field kinetic energy
three examples here okay so their job is
to define the most fundamental
measurable quantities that's what they
say measure define or measurable
quantities all they are they're thinking
about is measuring no they're not
talking about measuring they're talking
about defining the measurable
well so if something is measurable we
have to define that I think the word
corector the word they're trying to
emphasize is precisely or precise what
they're saying is the fine we're trying
to get a better accurate value of the
speed of light we're trying to get a
better or more accurate value of the
mass of the electron depends on how you
used or define but but I think that's
what what I'm saying is I think that's
what these guys have through their minds
they're saying precisely the most
fundamental measurable quantity shining
at the exact number of the speed of
light right that they think it's it's a
question of getting more accurate more
precise in in the values that we measure
in the fundamental quantities right but
I can
like that definition as it's written
because it more shows what you're trying
to do precisely defining like the words
defining the qualities of the
fundamental measurable quality if you
get into if you get into a precision
which is what these people are concerned
about apparently you know yeah but I'm
not concerned about getting a value I
don't I don't care the exact speed of
light it's fast
that's another language oh that's your
right and I think they're not referring
to that but if you refer oh yeah you
apply it to that yeah yeah if you
interpret it that way so you're closer
to the phoenicians yeah but then what's
the other one says find relationships
between those fundamental measured
quantities you know for example Newton's
laws conservation of energy special
relativity in other words what are they
saying they're saying not only do they
try to precisely define the measurable
quantities but they're also trying to
find relationships between those
measured quantities what is the
relationship of the speed of light I
don't know to the mass of the electron
or whatever and and I sort of think so
they're only again talking about
measurement they're talking about you
know what what they measure what they
can describe mathematically they're only
talking about quantities because you
only use words when you have to and
pictures because they're the best I mean
if you could do everything with pictures
and video right yeah yeah yeah yeah use
words there's money how they use them
these patterns are correlations are
express using words equations graphs
charts diagrams models and any other
means that allow us to express a
relationship right they're trying to hit
all the bases nobody know when they talk
about equation you never use equations
yes you don't really need a graph charts
diagrams models yeah yeah models in
words but only when you have to yeah and
in fact they don't use words that
the point the point is that they say
well you know words we can't really
express in words what we come up with
you know in on the blackboard and so
they don't really use words in other
words they don't care about what words
they use because they're using concepts
as objects obviously or do they use
models really because they just use kind
of who cares right but although they
call those models but then they when
they talk about models they're also
referring to their equations they're
saying we can paddle it with our
equation we can mold it with our
equation we can describe it with our
that's what they think in the word model
for them is something else it's not a
model airplane oh but even if it were
really when they talk about models or
depictions it's really just metaphors
right right and that's the point the
point is that their models are not
really models and it's not like you go
to the lab and say look I'm gonna build
a mock-up a physical mock-up of what I'm
saying they can't do that they can't do
that with particles they can't do with
anything the best they can probably do
is put it on on a video which they do
quite often but again we've got a
problem with that because it turns out
that you know when they do that they're
putting like particles and then you say
so so so you're saying that the quantum
world works with little balls oh no see
that's not really a ball that's a
wavefunction what so the particle is not
a particle a particle okay so what
happens with the qualitative I mean they
talk about quantity quantity so far
quantitatively describing with equation
what numbers lalala nothing about
qualitative and so here's here's a good
statement from one of those sources that
I just used and it says the far I love
this one if you were to reply with a
word Y meaning cause mechanism over and
over to whatever explanation a professor
were giving you the last and best
scientific answer he or he would give
you is most likely to be a law of
physics assuming they don't throw you
out of their office
before that point in other words they
they will not give you a why they will
not tell you a cause okay
they don't do causes they don't explain
why meaning they don't give you a
physical mechanism that you can take
home with you and say okay I see what
he's saying you know I see how want to
work they won't do that they'll just say
they'll just go back to a law of physics
so what does a law of physics mean it's
a mathematical but the point is I'm
talking about a magnet you know again we
we always talk about what one mechanism
is the car how a car works or another
one is how you know gravity works if you
can show a mess of physical mechanism to
someone of how gravity works or how a
magnet works well then people say well
you know and you don't have to believe
it but here's a mechanism that I've got
that I can propose that you can
understand you can visualize and say
okay I see what he's suggesting but they
can't do that they can't do that in in
for example in quantum mechanics you
know they can't explain like we talked
yesterday about and the day before about
mr. Carroll Sean Carroll and he gave
this gives us presentation on fields on
how fields bring two magnets together on
how fields intervene between the earth
and the moon what is a field well the
field is a bunch of numbers that that's
what he tells you he says there is a
value at each point in space and so you
can't explain the physical mechanism by
saying look a value at each point in
space brings the moon and the earth
together a value at each point in space
brings two magnets together a value at a
point in space keeps two magnets apart
stop from South you can't do that
because that's not an explanation and so
they don't have an explanation and so
yeah like like this guy just said says
you know you can't keep asking why
because the mathematicians just gonna
get upset he's gonna get you know pissed
at you saying
keep asking why but yeah I want a
mechanism and you can't give me one and
he said well you can't do you don't
understand if you're one way before I
don't ask you know why why why are there
threads yeah but what I'm saying here
well yeah but I'm saying here's
something I guess a little different
what you just stick to it's not just
that they have one wine behind me it's
that they can't at all at all give you a
mechanism with particles in other words
if quantum is the law of the land they
cannot produce attraction with their
particles no matter how they twist turn
it stand on their head they have to say
we don't really understand it very well
but we're research we're investigating
no it's conceptually wrong they will
never be able to explain it with
particles you can't explain
here I have particles I always like to
use my particles through my own
particles they're big particles okay
here's two particles there's no way
under quantum that you can have this
particle attract this one by throwing
particles at it or any way there's no
way you can explain it in any way shape
or form so quantum mechanics will never
have an answer for attraction never it
can't
it's just conceptually wrong you know
you can't have a bunch of universe full
of particles and have them attract each
other whether electrically magnetically
gravitationally and so what do they do
they cheat they say well see the way we
do attraction is with fields okay what
is a field what is it a hook it draws
the other particle no field it's just a
bunch of numbers in space I think it's
math I get more math more math and more
man I think the part that confuses the
whole thing is this chain of why's you
you go up the ladder right yeah before
we go down let's go up I think the up is
what confuses it because someone says
okay what makes the light turn on
someone says I don't know electricity
why and then they explain kind of the
you know you you you there's there's
wise before you get
- what is electricity I have no problem
with that no no that arguments correct
I think the confusing part is they go
okay we have all these wise above you
know why electricity you know why does
the particle move and why does he
electrum come on we have a whole bunch
of things we can't answer above that and
then when we since that's where we
stopped and no one's come up with a
better answer they go well that's just
the way it is
cuz that's kind of like the ground floor
that's as much as we know that's as much
as we can explain so that that is where
they just go that is the law yeah and
and where that fails again is that
that's just a bunch of description
because at the end of the day if you say
look you know how did the magnet attract
another well there's a field okay
there's a field and you say well what is
a field or why does a field act that way
well the guy can't yeah the Lord the guy
can't tell you can't give you a
mechanism how the field would bring two
magnets together and and so that's where
he says well we're still investigating
oh we don't know and that's a
qualitative question or that's ontology
or metaphysics or no we start with
Thursday I guess they are yeah yeah but
but why don't they just say look we
don't know we're ignorant we were but
then they tell you that they prove it
yeah but they're never see the point is
that it's conceptually wrong you can't
produce your traction the difference
whether they realize they're not as a
super separate issue but if I think that
I'm still investigating
I'm not lying or being disingenuous when
I say I don't know you know we're so
messy can you still I don't know you
know it's like a more diplomatic way of
saying yeah my problem with that is that
it's not a question of no knowledge in
other words that you can't say I don't
know you have to say look it's
conceptually wrong you will never be
able to explain it with particles and
and you know that should settle the
problem the issue because if you cannot
explain a mechanism with discrete
particles you know what do you know say
next well we don't know where the
particle moves that way or we don't know
why the gluon attracts two quarks
together
of course you don't know and you'll
never will because gluon has no way no
physical way of bringing two quarks
together it's a ball and if it's not a
ball what is it please tell me you know
and again it's these they elude the key
questions and that's not acceptable at
least in my philosophy okay so so what
happens when you ask a philosophical
question well they say that belongs to
the philosophy of physics that doesn't
belong to physics proper that's
philosophy and they called philosophy of
physics okay so what does philosophy of
physics study well it studies the
fundamental philosophical questions
underlying modern physics no that's
pretty straightforward right yes right
it studies the philosophical questions
raised right by the what they invested
what the physicists are investigating so
they say okay you guys need your physio
experiments your equations there we're
gonna interpret them and look at your or
look at your interpretations of them
okay we're gonna analyze your
interpretations of them right and and
they add the study of matter and energy
and how they interact and again they
introduce these words such as matter and
energy which the questions whether
energy especially you know has anything
to do with physics what is energy energy
is a concept in physics doesn't study
four concepts and so we have a problem
with that word energy in there has
nothing to do with physics or with
science it's a word of religion it's a
word that means spirit because no one
has defined it or given it ten
definitions and they just use that as a
joker in a rummy game you know they just
put it in there whenever they need it
they whenever they can't explain
something is a low energy you know and
so energy should belong in there the
philosophy of physics begins by
reflecting on the basic metaphysical see
now they shove you over to metaphysics
and epistemology epistemological
questions posed by physic causality
determinism and the nature of physical
law and Wikipedia ads the philosophy of
physics deals with conceptual and
interpretational issues in modern
physics specifically what are they
talking
well the important part well here this
is what they're talking about the
important part of physics whatever it
really wants to know qualitative stuff
and one of the reasons that you know
everyone wants to know yeah I want to
know the speed of light they want to
know why it is that that's one issue but
keep in mind that that we have also the
the issue that mathematicians are not
interested in the qualitative a sphere
they say well that's not alright we do
math we do quantitative quantities we do
equations we do numbers we don't do
interpret and we do interpretations but
we we don't give them any importance we
give that to the philosopher so they
have something to do they're trying to
have a movie in their head play and see
what's going on they don't care about
the numbers they don't care about how I
mean they don't care to some degree okay
Lane is fast
well there's 300,000 kilometers per hour
two hundred ninety thousand kilometers
per hour it's fast right
we're not Kerry nomal person who wants
to know they don't know they're not
looking for the exact numbers unless
they just want to be smarty pants look
at a party yeah but for someone really
wants to know you know what's the trick
you can't tell them to trade with
numbers alone but see that's the the
part of the issue that with which I
began like they said I think it was the
first prop there says that physics cast
changed over the years you know we had a
different type of physics before the
20th century it was known as classical
physics that died at the 20th century
and we went into quantum mechanics
general relativity what we call quantum
physics change and that's remember I
mentioned Max Born the other day he said
we went into abstractions and it turns
out the word abstraction is the opposite
of physical so we were from physical to
abstraction that's our physics that's
abstraction
that's too simple yeah but you guys
don't do they get your actions used to
use abstractions in your head to try to
figure out what the universe is doing it
but that doesn't mean you're not doing
physics no no I felt like you need the
blocks in your hand to know it's a
finger physics oh yeah but the the point
here that I'm trying to make at least
there with Max Born is that they did
something which is irrational which is
not just that they went into abstraction
we always try to think in the abstract
mode no doubt about it we try to figure
things out but that's not the point that
I'm trying I'm saying here that they're
using concepts as objects that's the
abstraction that they're using that's
the dangerous abstract because now
they're saying energy moved and mass
went up and force was carried by a
particle and that particle is not even a
particle it's a wavefunction and you
know they get into all this you know
world of dangerous black managed and not
even black because I mean this is just
totally Iraq you can't even not even God
can possibly imagine what they're
talking about what I think that modern
life it just has become more abstract
compared to the past you and me and
earth on there barely ever strike you
just had a rock stab to do we dealt with
more objects I mean right now we have
money we have the stock market we have
how much you know who is around me who's
next our neighbor when what day is it
all these weird thing that should not
give reason to a true genuine physicist
to use concepts in view of objects you
can talk about the market you can talk
about money going up or down you can
talk about all that but when you start
saying well you know I just moved love
from A to B you say oh Jesus you know I
think you need to see a special as long
as you're talking metaphorically yeah
yeah no problem but if you go into
proper physics proper and you say look I
just lifted space-time and I carried a
force no you can't talk like that not in
our song you literally conference
besides you know taking your ego and
titles of
nor is there's no metaphors in here yeah
even you kind of toed the line when you
talk about mother nature you know mother
nature knows etc etc there's no other
nation when you're in when I do that you
know I'm talking religion period you
know it's it's no problem I can sing in
and out you're cheating here know
everybody cheese and I and I'm a cheater
- no no problem I have no problem
accepting that I you know I bring stuff
from ordinary speech I do try to
convince people also that I'm not
supposed to but it's human nature to do
so but we have to we as the audience
were supposed to recognize those
elements as part of a religion that's
not physics that's not science it's only
explain different subjectively you use
it you don't use metaphor and the
crucial all right at the end it's when
they talk about closing arguments they
want to use a little poetry yeah bring
in poetry and this is the problem the
problem is that these people are using
concepts as objects and they and they're
not treating their explanations
literally in another room they say
particle they're not they don't mean a
particle they mean something else but
they say particle and they draw a
particle on the board and and you're
saying so so is that a particle that
you're doing your thing oh no that's not
a part you know that's not corpuscle do
you wanna do you have anything else to
say because I might I want to ask a
question of my dear a list okay that's
he yeah I have a couple more but yeah so
what's the point why why did this cuz
there's many many calm subjects in the
overall subject of science okay you know
we have biology with chemistry you have
an atom
whatever you whatever you want to break
them down right why did physics kind of
go off this weird tangent this weird
rail thing everyone has in the back of
their mind that physics is kind of like
the magical you know there's there's
there's extraordinary things happening
physics but biology is like chemistry
normal things now I know why you're my
son you always come up with these great
ideas that's a good one and a new one
for me I'll be honest that's a good
question
in other words chemistry they deal with
objects they don't talk about moving
energy and stuff like that they do bring
words such as energy and so on into
their thing but in general chemists in
Si has to deal with real stuff you know
at the lab at least and he's got to
explain that he kind of in general is
closer to reality okay he says look here
we have an atom well what's an atom well
I don't know exactly but look natum is
is a ball with a little electron there
and you know we we don't know this
little detail that's fine but we can see
how if we put this thing with this other
one creates this compound so they're
talking really about things in general
or closer to things these guys are off
on a tangent completely by the
physiology the doctor you know he wanna
do it open and literally see what we
have to explain Ryan the guy has to deal
with hearts with livers with veins with
real things I guess that's the
difference music physicists their
literal job is to explain the UH
invisible and I think that's why they
can't do that that's what the biologist
is cutting a thing open they're touching
it they're looking at it they're hearing
in you they have something real their
chemists also you we have fizzing things
you know okay I don't know I mean we
can't zoo chemists is a better example
so we can't really see the carbon atom
or the you know let's take sodium
chloride or whatever you can't see those
atoms but you can see their face right
in front of your eyes you can do as many
times as you want but gravity is this
weird like but you know you know the
chemist you know because we have imaged
atoms the way we did it we bounce call
them electrons you know you've got the
the SEM scanning electron microscopes
which I use personally myself
you put something on there you can see
things very very you know you can
magnify them tremendously and you know
iBM has pictures on the internet where
they took pictures maybe not of an
individual Adam you can't see the
electron rolling around and they
probably never will but they can see
like an array of atoms attached to atoms
forming you know this platform and they
said look we can make more or less get a
picture of you know the crystal
structure of how the ends are arranged
in there so so it up to that point the
chemist is okay he's still in the
ballpark he says look I can't tell you
exactly on the structure of one atom but
I can show you that all these atoms how
they're connected you know in a crystal
how they're arranged in the crystal
structure so the chemist is realistic -
up to that point he's realistic zoomed
in you can count them yeah you can count
but you can't see like the electron
zooming around you know no no right and
so this is the issue the issue is that
you know the the chemist says quote is
is maybe intermediate between rational
science and physics and then and then
you have all the guys who are in
classical mechanics all those people
like doctors and so on paleontologists
they deal with bones you know and they
say ok that's what we know know they
deal with crazy stuff but this is the
point no this is the point of timing the
paleontologist he says look the Nano
thoughts made it with humans and we can
see it here in the DNA you don't have to
agree with them you don't have to agree
with it my point my point here is that
they can look at the molecule they can
look at the molecule and they can say
look here we have a carbon atom this is
how this is structured according to the
chemists right and we think of them as
balls whatever fine they're all attached
we don't deal with the atomic level we
just deal with the whole molecule and
say this is a DNA and this DNA strand is
different than this one matches this one
you know they can do that kind of stuff
so they also in it's the geneticists but
you know the paleontologist he finds a
bone he says well I think this belongs
to me and oh yeah so again
it's not too deep into it but
paleontologists also have to do a lot of
theater izing yes but my point is they
you're trying to solve a case this law
yes right I think what else what I'm
saying what I'm saying here is that the
paleontologists he doesn't say the force
did this or you know mass created this
bone in the rock they don't use these
words as objects that's my point
yeah they have weird theories I find
some people like one theory and other
people like another but they don't have
to use concepts as objects that's
exclusively a physicist oh right that's
that's where you're such a smart
literally pointing at the things they're
naming so they don't have to do this
weird okay that's a mass that was a very
good observation even though
observations not part of science but
that was a very good observation okay
let me finish this up here here's the
first one this these are the notions I
got other Cora page where they can say
what is physics these are just
statements that I pulled out of there
some of them are out of context but you
get the overall idea the study of matter
in its motion behavior of matter through
space and time concepts such as energy
and force the nature and properties of
matter and energy always that word
energy in their mathematical models
conceptual objects mathematical models
work when we can use them to predict
conduct experiments okay these are the
notions that people have these are
statements that I pulled out or phrases
that I pulled out machines that perform
tasks with predictable results advances
in new technologies these are the
concepts people have of what physics is
or what it's about or what it's supposed
to do what physicists do physics has
nothing to do with ontology ontology
meaning we don't care what the meaning
of something is
we don't have to explain it well all we
do is physics so what do you mean visit
what we do math that's what we do we do
equations we describe things nothing to
do with nature of reality look at that
it has nothing to do with the nature
reality being non-being in other words
reality here is taken as a synonym of
being of non-being we say what doesn't
exist me well it means means being and
in that sense it's use so it's nothing
to do with the nature of reality
formulations of physics represent fields
and forms these are formulations
represent fields so they have the word
fields energy and you can see they put
them in quotes because they don't know
what a field is and so they say well you
know they represent fields so what do
you mean represents me what is a field
you know these exist only as conceptions
so again they don't exist a physical
object these people are not talking
about obvious yeah they're talking about
concepts and they're using these
concepts as objects that's essentially
what they're saying an existing consent
well because these people think that
concepts exist like love exists in that
sense is that which is the usage in
ordinary speech and they say all forms
can be described using maths so so who
cares so who give bragging dvv find a
circle you know or a circumference PI R
squared whatever with an A with math who
cares about essentially describing a
circle with just different words if I
wanted to describe this horseshoe shape
right yeah in math with math I can
describe using words right like this
someone who's never seen horses before
or if he understands math I could just
give him the mathematical formula but
all I'm really doing is just describing
describing but but look I can say a
chair you know I described a cherry as a
backrest
four legs one seat you know if you want
to two armrests so if you wanted
mathematically there it is and is that
science but just a description you know
that's that's the point I'm trying to
make science is not a description airs
yeah I mean you're gonna do well but I'm
saying what I'm saying here is that I
can describe it mathematically you know
for example these guys they're saying
off words can be described using mass
here a describe the form I called a
chair I described it with math I can
even tell you how long it is you know I
can go with more details in numbers is
that math is that physics I mean if I
just say light travels at 300,000
kilometers per second is that physics
sounds physic he sounds physically but
it's not just like describing your
chairs like saying well the chair has
four legs
you know I described it mathematically
you know it's like walked into a party
and said light travels at 300,000
kilometers per hour ya know I'm a dish
physics deals in conceptual numbers and
forms but physics does not deal in
meaning meaning is applied to the
equations of physics to explain their
significance physics does not explain
meaning meaning is applied to the
equations of physics to explain their
significance in other words I'm not even
sure because they use these words like
meaning and significance and you say but
what do you mean by meaning what do you
mean by significance I'm sure the guy
wouldn't be able to tell you I mean yeah
I have a very the word meaning okay
these guys are just kind of using them
interchangeably throwing around maybe we
should have a tete-a-tete on that
because I'm saying that definition is
what the prosecutor does meaning is what
the jury gets meaning is what what the
listener gets from what the other guy
defined so the definition and meaning
are not the same definition has a
different notion it's what someone gives
whereas meaning is when someone gets and
and that could be the same prosecutor
for that question what did you mean by
that
no no it's a it's a valid question
because I didn't understand your
definition but what did you mean you
can't mean right right what did you mean
but okay there's a saying
I didn't understand your meaning would
be the correct we have set a formulating
that scientific because my point is that
I didn't get the meaning yeah I I didn't
you know calibrated in my mind it didn't
it didn't go through the fire the works
in there you know yeah and let me put a
final notion here and as mr. Donald
semanek he's a emeritus professor at
Lock Haven University I think that's uh
is that what do they study there this
Loch Ness monster Lock Haven maybe
that's what they study with well anyway
so science doesn't explain science
describes he just yeah so you don't have
to kill yourself trying to figure out
what science is or what physi because
they equate science with fission he's a
physicist and they're saying you know
science is not about it explaining so so
the question that I've got just as a
summary here we have two magnets right
and this one attracts that so explaining
how a magnet attracts another is not a
part of physics I drop a pen to the
floor all right drop to let go of a pen
it falls to the floor I do it a million
times just to make sure that it's
repeatable because they always look at
that word repeatable and you know
explaining that phenomena is not a part
of physics I mean if we're gonna exclude
these
observations these experiments these
phenomena from physics you know then
we're left only with math means this is
outside of the bounds of physics that's
where I have a problem because these
people never get to that because it we
don't we don't explain it's like it's
like Mary Poppins you know the banker
asks her mr. banks you know he says can
you please explain the meaning of this
and she says first I want you to get one
thing clear yes
I never explain anything
and that's exactly what the
mathematician would answer to you
I never explained any they don't explain
they describe and and the question is
whether that equates to physics yes yeah
you got a black guy that the good
sparring partner my son no we do good
sparring here love that clusion in a
nutshell is basically explanation is
description description is static parts
when I'm talking about like let's take
the okay the description is just the
essentially what mathematics does you
give the shape of the car you give the
shape of of all the parts you can
essentially apart from each other you
don't assemble them essentially all part
yeah Marseille measure how big they are
at all the descriptions right that we
can all understand it's just all the
pieces right that's your stocks
planation is how guess the the whole
thing works essentially from gas to
wheels and and all the important parts
but narration was this weird gray zone
between the two that we kind of found
out where you can kind of narrate the
gas going in basically the step by step
it's kind of like this description in
motion it's a chronological description
of motion it's like I used the analogy
to my son the other day in the kitchen
when I said you know the the policeman
comes to the lady's door says what
happened and she says you know this red
car ran so fast he hit a lady
just the facts please just the facts so
they don't want you to you know give
your personal interpretation just just
the facts you know and the objective
facts is fine you know you said look
there's gas in a car it goes through
this pipe make those over here this you
know you describe it first you describe
it with all the parts were
gas goes through how and how it reaches
the wheel that's a region okay right
right
first is the description just each part
separately no map no motion is correct
no motion just a description of the
parts that's description of objects now
you're going to narrative or narration
and what is that that's now you're gonna
set your parts in motion and you're
gonna relate them one to another we two
separate that from description static
description of a static object
standalone object we'll use the word
narrative or narration narration they
are very different right they are
different in there and they're like a
half-breed or a way between explanation
and description now we're gonna just
describe in motion kind of kind of like
a movie but not quite we're just gonna
yeah but we're gonna look at each frame
like set like a picture there is a movie
there because you're gonna go
chronologically there's gonna be some
motion from one friend to the other
there's gonna be that but you're going
to look at each picture like separately
so you're still you you still haven't
rolled the tape that's what I'm saying
you're not scanning the tape it's not
showing in the screen it's like you
bring someone to watch a film strip with
all the with all the frames and the
guide looks at the first frame looks at
the second third one he still doesn't
get the ID he gets the flow he's okay so
it goes from the gas to the pipe okay
and the pipe takes it to the engine and
the engine takes it you know goes using
carburetors oh yeah he gets the pieces
and he gets him in chronological order
too because the the tape films take you
know the UH all the frames are you know
in chronological order but in order to
have an explanation you really have to
wind the tape and show the movie the
video you have to see this whole thing
in motion then the guy says okay now I
see this going in there okay I see how
it's turning the wheels you didn't see
that really with a narrative because the
narrative is like a way
you know a station between both of that
I think that's kind of a cheat okay
you're essentially you're essentially
turning the movie into a freeze-frame
yeah with this movie reel analogy but a
narrative isn't really is it really like
but uh you know to be married could be
an explanation is what I was saying
because you could just narrow you can
essentially a narrative could also it's
basically a movie in words that's what a
narrative yeah but again like you said
scene words but not not a film on the
screen that's my point my point is that
it's it's watching each frame separately
like you bring someone and say look
here's the film of what I film right and
the guys looks at the different frames
and gets the overall picture of what the
flow was chronological flow but he still
doesn't understand the theory the
mechanism for that he might have to
watch the movie and have some words in
behind from you saying look this is this
this is the critical part pay attention
here or whatever or this how I did this
little part here and then you get the
better picture and it's like an
explanation is not quite a narrative
which is not quite a description we're
all separate narrative was an
explanation kind of gets to the crux of
the matter or whatever your question was
that's what we're gonna that's whatever
is important to the question that's what
I'm gonna bring up well with a narrative
you can vary the color of the pieces you
can narrate a whole bunch of irrelevant
difference between an explanation their
narrative you literally describe narrate
any every single thing that's happening
every single bit of this car that is
completely irrelevant to how a car works
well with an explanation you kind of put
all that by the way you kind of remove
everything that's irrelevant to
explaining how the car works yeah we
probably need to hash that out a little
more for sure but the point here is that
we have this word which is not used at
all anywhere that I couldn't think of
narrative or narration and that's like
where we're getting tripped when
mathematician like Sean Carroll says oh
we know how a magnet works well yeah
because they use the word description
the way kind of you used it like a
minute ago I'm gonna use description and
narrative interchangeably for a second
because people think that if I describe
then I have explained it but because
they're using the word described as
narrative that's an area they're talking
about described as a man described
everything that's happening
chronologically but that's in motion so
it's not a description anymore
right ray it's not a description and
that's why you know we have to separate
these words because I think we're
getting tripped on the word narrative
there's a scientifically defining
categorizing these three words in there
yeah for sure I think I've separated
explanation from description the
question now is to get a more fine-tuned
definition what a narrative is and with
that we will see you tomorrow and we'll
see that same times at the same station
bye bye